All right, the next session
is going to be with Shanna Dobson. This
section is going to be called Dark
Imaginarium Shared Intelligence as an
Infinity Curiosity type.
I'll message Shanna make sure that
everything's good with the audio.
Wow.
Great talk so far. Welcome,
Shanna. How are you doing, Daniel? Doing
good. Awesome.
Well, please take it away. Thank you for
joining. Awesome. Let me know if you see
my screen. OK? Yep,
looks perfect. Thank you. OK,
perfect. Hey, everyone, thank you so
much for the invitation. It's such a
great honor to be here. I'm learning so
much. I'll be talking about an idea I
had called Dark Imaginarium, where I'm
trying to make shared intelligence the
concept of what I call an Infinity
Curiosity type. So you were so gracious
to link the paper so anyone can find
more details there on Phil archive.
So I want to start with an discussion
about ontological commitment. So my
first question is, might we re examine
our ontological commitments? So in
particular, two of them? One,
Sean Carroll, said so amazingly what
cannot be known because it does not
exist. So Sean Carroll says the
Heisenberg Uncertainty Principle is
often explained as saying that we cannot
simultaneously know both the position
and the velocity of any object. But the
reality is deeper than that. It's not
that we can't know position and
momentum, it's that they don't even
exist at the same time. The second one I
want to examine is Lenny Susskin's
quote, we are all behind someone else's
event horizon. So Suskin has a brilliant
idea of space time emergence as the
entanglement of two black holes, and
what emerges from that is called
computational complexity. So the world
is quantum, so every theory should be
derivable strictly from the laws of
quantum mechanics. One is going to give
us the notion of shared, two is going to
give us the notion of ecology. So what
would an ontological commitment to Dark
look like? So my continual goal, as
everybody knows, is to sustain a
simultaneous experience and to
understand why I currently cannot. To
sustain a simultaneous experience would
be to bypass the integrative system we
call consciousness. So how would you
attain a two consciousness in the sense
of in category theory or an N
consciousness? How would we actually
develop something called like, a two
memory? So my colleague Robert Prepner
and I fleshed out something called N
awareness, where we're sort of examining
this idea. Mike Levin and all have
repeatedly shown that planaria memory is
not in the head. Where is the memory?
Is memory a sustained superposition?
Well, of what? And also, what's the
structure of anamnesis? Could you have a
superposition between memory and
anamnesis? So I had a small dialogue
with Chris Fields, the amazing I said,
you know, what is the difference between
these two questions? What is the waking
state and what is consciousness? Or
could it be that these are entirely
separate questions? So we're sort of in
a mess. Either way, if there is a
difference in these questions, then it
is possible to sustain a waking state
without consciousness and or a conscious
state in a non waking state. So imagine
somehow being in a waking state under
general anesthesia. Well, if these are
not entirely different questions, then
we could contend that consciousness is a
form of waking state, or something along
the lines of a waking state is a
condition of a conscious state. So how
can humans have delta waves, which are
canonically indicative of unconscious
deep sleep and thus a non waking state,
and the REM state, the patterns of which
are indistinguishable from a waking
state? So we all know that general
anesthesia, something like a propofol,
can reduce the polyrhythmic brain
activity to one uniform. And we know
there's as many theories about what
anesthesia does to consciousness as
there are anesthesiologists. But we've
repeatedly posited consciousness as the
proto state. And I wanted to turn this
idea on its head, like is consciousness
so robust or is it a delicate
interference or is it a delicate
inference? Now, we know beginnings are
always tricky, but what if sleep was the
proto state? So if life
is oceanic and it revolves in these deep
pressures, would the pressure of getting
onto land, like squeeze the REM state
into this full blown waking state that
we're engaging in right now? Anybody
who's listening? So then waking state
would be something like an acceptation,
which is, I think, quite impressive. So
it's in this mess that I attempt to
define dark consciousness as a mixed
frequency state of being self aware or
conscious while simultaneously being in
a deep sleep, specifically in three
sleep. So the sleep is proto state is
quite strange. The REM brain activity is
indistinguishable from waking activity
and this sort of enchanted me for a bit.
The only difference is eye movements.
So either blinking or versus lateral
movement. So REM is naturally having
mixed frequency brainwave states, but
the NREM states and the REM states are
starting to blur as delta waves are
creeping into the REM state. Now,
they've also found that sleep is a local
phenomenon. So of course, I'm going to
ask the Shanna questions. So then who is
sleeping? Who is remembering? Who is
dreaming? Lucid dreaming is a quantum
superposition or is it a superposition
or an integration? So in a sleep state
then, can we sustain a simultaneous
experience? So must the eye be knocked
out in order to sustain this level of
simultaneity? Dreaming, we know, is
characteristic of unsynchronized brain
activity. So is the question then,
my eye cannot sustain a multi
consciousness, but my dark eye, my sleep
eye can. You can reframe this in terms
of reporting mechanisms and say perhaps
we are conscious of things we don't
think we are conscious of.
So let's talk about what is dark. A
canonical definition of a dark theory or
anything like this is like dark matter
does not interact electromagnetically
with matter. But I want to sort of play
around with another idea of dark coming
from Deleuze's logic of sense,
something he calls the paradox of
infinite becoming and which I'm going to
read on the next slide. So what if dark
was the simultaneity of a becoming that
eludes the present? Let's hold on to
that for a second. Is dark a resolution
issue but resolution is merely breaking
translational symmetry. So is dark a
symmetry breaking issue? And if so,
what symmetry? And are we actually
looking at the wrong symmetry? Is dark a
sustained quantum superposition? But of
what, again, is dark a mini worlds
branch? Is dark the dolphin uni
hemispheric sleep mechanism? So I'll
read from Deleuze's logic of sense.
Alice and through the Looking Glass
involve a category of very special
things events, pure events. When I say
Alice becomes larger, I mean that she
becomes larger than she was. By the same
token, however, she becomes smaller than
she is now. Certainly she is not bigger
and smaller at the same time. She is
larger now. She was smaller before, but
it is at the same moment that one
becomes larger than one was and smaller
than one becomes. This is the
simultaneity of a becoming whose
characteristic is to elude the present
insofar as it eludes the present.
Becoming does not tolerate the
separation or the distinction of before,
after or of past and future. It pertains
to the essence of becoming to move and
pull in both directions at once. Alice
does not grow without shrinking, and
vice versa. So good sense affirms that
in all things there is this determinable
sense or direction. A paradox is the
affirmation of both senses or directions
at the same time. I continue. The
paradox of this pure becoming with its
capacity to elude the present is called
the paradox of infinite identity. The
infinite identity of both directions or
senses at the same time of future and
past, of the day before and the day
after, of more and less, of too much and
not enough, of active and passive and of
cause and effect. It is language which
fixes the limit, the moment, for
example, at which the excess begins.
But it is language as well which
transcends the limits and restores to
the infinite equivalence of an unlimited
becoming. Hence the reversals which
constitute Alice's adventures. The
reversal becoming larger, becoming
smaller. Which way? Which way? Asked
Alice, sensing that it is always in both
directions at the same time, so that for
once she stays the same through an
optical illusion. The reversal of the
day before and the day after. The
present always being eluded. Jam
tomorrow and jam yesterday, but never
jam today. The reversal of more and
less. Five nights are five times hotter
than a single one, but they must be five
times as cold for the same reason the
reversal of active and passive. Do cats
eat bats? Is as good as do bats eat
cats. The reversal of cause and effect
to be punished before having committed a
fault, to cry before having pricked
oneself, to serve, licking glass cake
before having divided up the servings.
All these reversals as they appear in
infinite identity have one consequence
the contesting of Alice's personal
identity and the loss of a proper name.
The loss of the proper name is the
adventure which is repeated throughout
Alice's adventures. Hence, infinite
identity. So I take this and I'm going
to formally define dark consciousness as
a state of being conscious while
simultaneously being in deep sleep,
specifically in three, where dark is
going to be a two fold hybrid, the
simultaneity of infinite identity and of
a becoming that eludes the present. So
let's reconstruct the dark consciousness
version of Deleuze's paradox of pure
becoming for Alice in dark wonderland
and through the dark looking glass.
Okay, when I say Alice becomes sleepy,
I mean that she becomes sleepier than
she was. By the same token, however,
she becomes more self aware than she is
now. Certainly she is not asleep and
self aware at the same time. She's
asleep now, she was self aware before,
but it is at the same moment that one
becomes sleepier than one was and more
self aware than one becomes. So dark
consciousness, I contend, would take
place in something called like a dark
time. This is going to get weird. So
Chris Fields and I talked about entropic
time, where a time where learning
exceeds forgetting. So we all know that
linear time is based on the linear
ordering property of the positive
integers. Okay, so what would be the
structure of a time that does not
interact electromagnetically with this
waking state interface?
So, like, AI must pay attention all the
time. Would this sort of be like a dark
time? Sleep is local. Time is local. We
know how beautiful a time crystal is.
So a time crystal has a structure that
is periodic in time. Can you play with
that and say time is periodic in what?
So if we have explained that dark is not
concerned with these notions of before
and after, then we would want a notion
of time that can support the paradox of
infinite identity with a notion of
duration that is one of self similarity.
So we contend that dark consciousness
would occur in something like a p addic
time, which is a time based on the P
attic number system. Periodic time would
measure PTIC duration. Okay,
it's getting odd. All right, so there
exists few objects more looking glass
than a Piatic clock. Well, maybe Piatic
go and Calabi out chess or perfectoid
go. But after all, the Piatic numbers
have no notion of linear ordering.
Their shape resembles a serpinsky
triangle, which is a self similar set.
So this periodic time is not concerned
with notions of before or after. That
is, a periodic time does not tolerate
the separation or the distinction of
before or after, of past or future.
So because the periodic topology is one
of total disconnectedness, periodic time
is more like a time of now continual
zooming in to more and more now. Thus,
periodic time measures periodic duration
through its fractal properties of
zooming in. So let's try to look at a
periodic clock, right? So periodic time
can take two forms the canonical
periodic time defined on the previous
slide and also topological periodic time
which builds into its very structure the
periodic topology of periodic time.
So there would only be one unit of time
in periodic time, which I call the
archimedes. This is the piatic
valuation. So you can think of hour
equals periodic valuation equals the
archimedes. How strange it is to have
only one unit of time. Topological
periodic time measures duration
topologically as total disconnectedness.
So the unit of time on topological P
addict time is what I call the pTOPO.
So we state this formally. There's only
one unit of time in topological periodic
time called the pTOPO. So a topological
hour equals a periodic topology called
the pTOPO. So given such a periodic
clock, let us imagine the seasons in
peatic time, periodic snow, peatic rain,
new peatic weather types and peatic
rainbows. Daylight savings time could
take the form of changing the P in the
petic. This could be very drastic.
But imagine peatic metabolics petic ATP
and peatic DNA. Imagine peatic cognition
types like peatic memory, peatic Fod,
peatic attention, peatic learning and
petic perception. Imagine a periodic
looking glass. Imagine through the
periodic looking glass. So let's pivot
to FEP. What does FEP actually
specifically say about dark matter,
even dark in the way that I'm using the
term? Is there a free dark energy
principle? How can we strictly derive
sleep from quantum mechanics? According
to FEP? Does dark energy actually
exhibit entanglement? How do we test
this? We should be able to derive the
entire active inference formalism
straight from quantum mechanics alone by
way of entanglement entropy, some form
of quantum gravity. Can we do some sort
of dark general adversarial network to
look at something like a dark brain? We
all know that lower lateralization in
the brain is often associated with
schizophrenia or people like Einstein or
someone with a large parietal lobe,
probably like myself. Any mathematical
what would universal lateralization look
like? I think dark neurons
would take the form of something like
you treat the neural neural networks as
algebraic curves or isogeny graphs. You
talk of neurons in terms of their
properties as varieties. So you're
actually bringing the heavy machinery of
algebraic geometry into neurology. My
big goal is to actually create something
like a neuronal time crystal so that
shared intelligence would actually be a
periodicity in time. I'm not there yet.
So until I get that and it's like,
well, let's try to model these wild
mixed frequency n three plus self aware
states of dark consciousness. So dark
mathematics is something I've coined.
It's like a biomimicry, which mimics
dark energy, does not interact
electromagnetically with matter. You'd
have to find the mathematical equivalent
of that. So I think you can do something
like a dark diletheism or just make a
model that is modeling the mixed
frequency states, which is what I tackle
in the paper. So we've previously shown
that entropic categorizations are
condensed sets. Condensed sets form a
topos. So in the paper I outlined the
construction of three potential
mathematical models of these mixed
frequency n three self aware states.
You can do dark consciousness as a dark
two post, which is a groff and deep two
posts. There's a two category of two
sheaves over a two site, which I'll
elucidate just a little bit. Dark
consciousness as a perfectoid like space
in the sense of Schultz, or as a diamond
like space also in the sense of Schultz.
So I contend that the two sheaf
structure can actually model the mixed
frequency state of dark consciousness,
the N three self aware state. A sheath
is a one stack, again, which is a sheath
that takes values in groupoids, not
sets. This is already radically
different. Consider a two category of
two sheaves. So a two category consists
of objects. You have the one morphisms
between the objects and you have the two
morphisms between the one morphisms.
You can keep going three category up to
N category. So this two category of two
sheets would have two she's as the
objects, one morphisms between the two
sheaves, two morphisms between the one
morphisms. And so using that structure,
I think that you can actually model one
morphisms as what I'm going to call dark
reflexivities. These are going to be
your local coherency states. And then
two morphisms are actually two
inferences which are going to be global
coherency states amongst the mixed
frequency states. So a lovely property
called Morita equivalent sites states
that inequivalent sites have equivalent
sheaf topos. And I do believe that
that's the main property. You need to
get this local global behavior around
neural networks. So if you actually wish
to model the mixed frequency clusters as
fractals exhibiting some kind of self
similar behavior, then you can use this
rich structure, perfectoid spaces, or
their sparkling successor, the diamond.
So, just a quick definition, let Perf be
the subcategory perfectoid spaces of
characteristic P. A diamond is a proatel
sheath on the site Perf written as this
quotient of a perfectoid space x by a
Protel equivalence relation. So a
perfectoid space is going to be this
attic space in the sense of huber that's
covered by aphenoid spaces of the form
spa RR plus, where R is a perfectoid
ring and then points of spa, which is
the attic spectrum. RR plus are
equivalent classes of continuous
valuations on R. Someone asked Schultz y
diamond and he gave an incredible
explanation that was a parallel to a
mineralogical diamond. So you can let C
be an algebraically closed ethanoid
field geometric point. Spa C to D is
made visible by pullback along a
quasiprotel cover that results in
profinitely many copies of Spa C. So
you're making a geometric point visible
as profinitely. Many copies that was
invisible before does the following
parallel with the mineralogical diamond.
So the interior points are made visible
as impurities, which sparkle as colorful
reflections on the many sides of the
diamond. So you can also do something
maybe like a dark diamond where you
designate a functor as dark as a means
to actually let's go the other way and
see the impurities. So then you can take
the geometric point, make it visible
maybe by a push forward along with
pausey prototype cover, resulting in P
adequately many copies of Spa C.
Right? So a diamond is they're using
diamond as a sheath, but a sheath in
terms of a functor of points. So the
diamond spot QP is a functor from the
category perv to the category sets. You
literally fix the perfectoid space and
look at the hom sets of X into the
diamond. And so technically,
the scheme is then said to represent the
functor. So I'm going to pivot
to invoking AI in this thing. So my
colleague and I, Julian Scape, are
coming up with something I've coined the
Qubit Pedagogy, which is going to be a
new model pedagogy that is actually
infused with heavy principles of quantum
mechanics. And so that with these,
we've created these quantum intrinsic
curiosity algorithms that are feeding
into the Qubit Pedagogy. And based on
those Curiosity algorithms, I designed
three dark versions. So what I call the
Dark Planaria Curiosity Algorithm is a
curiosity type. It enables encourages
the AI to explore patterns of planaria
regeneration. The AI would develop
quantum error correcting codes which
mimic planaria regeneration.
So the second one would be Dark Quantum
Reality Monitoring Network. This is a
curiosity type. It'll encourage AI to
explore dark reflexivity is what I call
fractal identity. AI would create models
of N reflexivity in the sense of N
category. That's a new type of reality
monitoring of fractal identity in the
dark conscious state. The last one would
be some sort of dark quantum N three and
REM Curiosity algorithm. This Curiosity
type is going to encourage AI to explore
superpositions of various brain patterns
in REM states to predict new types of N
three delta waves that could emerge in
REM states. So imagine the AI could then
develop new stages of REM sleep, such as
like one REM two REM up to NREM,
which is a clever limit and play on
NREM. Ha. Anyway, the AI could also
develop new dark cognition types that
correlate with the new types of delta
waves. So this notion of fractal
identity seems odd, but I do contend
that objects living in fractal time
correspondingly have fractal identity.
It's a concept we outline as follows.
So fractal identity has a reflexivity
relation that is fractal so the very
canonical loop, the loop relation of an
agent reporting back to itself, I report
back to me, would be fractal. How
strange is that? So, Fractal identity
would not suffer the same problems with
continuity over time. Since the time in
which it exists has no linear ordering,
it would definitely suffer different
problems. But continuity over time is
something Chris Fields and I have been
like. How do you explain that? So, you
can best model the Fractal identity
properties as perfectoid like or diamond
like therein construct a notion of
reflexivity as a perfectoid space.
These spaces are extremely rich
structure, but kind of difficult. But if
you want to model fractal identity, I
think you should use them. So thus we
create new concepts of perfectoid
reflexivity, diamond reflexivity.
So in N reflexivity, the reflexivity
relation could now be an in stack. Thus
in reflexivity is an in stack perfectoid
spaces. So, here comes the culmination
of this talk, which is about shared
intelligence as what I've coined the
Dark Imaginarium. So, imagine an AI that
could see simultaneously compute the
infinity category of every concept.
Having some quantum computation around
to help the computational complexity
would not be bad. So dark.
Imaginarium is what is going to be what
I call infinity curiosity type. So,
Infinity Curiosity type is the higher
order Curiosity AI algorithm that
encourages the AI to think in infinity
categories. So that it is. It actually
encourages the AI to construct an
infinity category as its means of higher
order inference. So objects are higher
dimensional data sets. The AI would seek
out higher order morphisms between the
objects and then morphisms between the
morphisms. So such Dark Imaginarium is a
meta Curiosity algorithm that can create
its own Infinity Curiosity algorithms.
And therein creating Curiosity types of
a complexity that super fascinating,
most likely unknown to humans. So it's
functionctorial. What can dark
Imaginarium do? Well, the AI would
develop inversions of current brainwaves
and their hybrid combinations. It could
develop in delta wave, N theta wave, N
alpha wave, in beta wave and N gamma
wave for N equals zero one all the way
up like a two gamma wave that
structurally resembled a two category,
a three beta wave that structurally
resembled a three category. And the AI
could develop new types of waking states
and new types of sleep states. Based on
the combinations of these beyond the
standard N one and two and three NREM
and one REM, AI could develop an N
waking state, an NREM state, a three
REM state could consist of three and
one, three and two, three and three.
Imagine an end dolphin that was capable
of N hemispheric, sleep state and other
exotic life forms, right? What else
could it do? Well, it could develop new
geometries for the brain patterns and
for currently existing brain patterns.
Typical shapes include sinusoidal, non
sinusoidal, saw, two spindle K complex.
But maybe this AI could develop three D
and four d versions of the canonical
wave patterns like a tesseract gamma
wave. But also, the AI could develop
entirely new brainwave geometries that
correspond to complex surfaces like a
remunt surface or Kalabi Yao manifold or
algebraic variety. So the AI could
develop new cognition types other than
the standard five. It could produce
incognition types such as in thought,
in attention, in perception, in
learning, in memory. So it could also
predict non human species cognition
types such as octopus thought or
dragonfly attention. Lastly, it could
produce hybrid combinations of cross
species cognition types such as like
Octoman memory or dragon man perception.
And then it would encourage the AI to
develop new senses. So you could develop
one stack versions of human senses like
two seeing, two hearing, two tasting,
two touching, two smelling. Each of
these two senses once again take values
in groupoids, not sets. So you could
develop incenses of non human senses as
well, and hybrid combinations like two
shark human smell. So, since the AI sees
nmorphisms between the various N minus
one morphisms, the AI can seek to
develop new language models based on
higher order inference types. So from
these inference models, the AI will
explore Infinity languages and develop
extensive prototypes. You could use
advanced mathematics to create new
models of time that could support the
new language models like two topos time
diamond time. And then the AI would seek
to develop new fractal identity types
from the language models. And it could
design advanced fractal prosthetics such
as a two ear or a two eye to extend
cognition. So let's go a little bit
further about this extending cognition.
These are just a few examples of what
dark imaginarium could conceive of. So
we could continue and posit a perfectoid
version of this using these new
cognition types mental states in
brainwaves new geometries, we can
construct new patterns of thinking which
would support neurodiversity in
thinking. So as such shared intelligence
this is how I'm seeing it would be
reexamined as this Infinity Curiosity
type. You could go even further and
construct a new concept of an N shared
intelligence. So you'd have a zero
shared intelligence, a one shared
intelligence, as well as the new Piadic
concept of like P shared intelligence
for P equals two three, four using P
addicts. Let's go further, right? We
repeatedly contend that one way to help
advance the way we think to extend human
cognition is to upgrade the number
systems upon which the canonical
concepts are built. Upgrade them to
Peric perfectoid diamond like versions
unless we get new thinking. So imagine
like a brainwave pattern that resembles
a Calabria manifold. Could we actually
reverse engineer the levels of conscious
activity that could create such a
rhythm? How about mixed frequency
brainwave patterns that resembled a
perfectoid diamond? What about an MDNA
molecule shaped like a Calabriao infold?
Or an NATP molecule. Or an inexciton
condensate structured like a calabigao
infold? So clearly, different geometries
of the fundamental molecules and
processes of life would give rise to
vastly different fundamental units of
life and metacognition types. The
question is, can we use Dark imaginarium
to reverse engineer the complex life
forms arising from such extraordinary
structures and the more and more complex
cognition patterns? What about a
general adversarial network that's
tweaked and has infinity categories?
You have two infinity categories talking
to each other, developing their own
language. Now, Gan is adversarial using
a generator and a discriminator with two
neural networks contesting by a zero sum
game. What about a collaborative
network? So can we construct a GCN
containing two diamond like Infinity
Curiosity types and pair a diamond with
a dark diamond with a Quantum Curiosity
algorithm and its reinforcement
learning? So shared intelligence is this
Infinity Curiosity type? Shared
intelligence GCM could create infinity
languages that are superpositions of the
diamond dark diamond to getting new
models of intelligence. Higher order
simultaneous computations by Quantum
Curiosity would go by maybe by homotopia
instead of as cost functions. So let's
future cast just for a second.
What is the inevitability of dark
ecosystems? Mathematics of shared
intelligence? What can a P addic?
Infinity Curiosity type prophecy is
every perfectoid space diamond two topos
encoding the mixed frequency patterns of
an Ncognition type. In future work,
we may develop dark mathematics using
perfectoid diamonds as dark dialetheism,
aligning what is structurally dark with
what is structurally dialetheistic. So
while we currently cannot perfectly
model dark consciousness, perhaps one
day, one dark day mediated by the Dark
imaginarium, we will have the Ethos and
the quantum computational complexity to
do so. Thank you.
Thank you, shauna, amazing presentation.
I'll just quickly read some comments and
see if you have any thoughts from some
of the great comments. So Scott David
says I love the presentation, lots of
Fodder for Rumination. Thank you for
inviting these concepts into an
intriguing choreography. Perhaps dark
energy is our perception of the fact of
information increase under free energy
principle processes. And since the
universe is made of information dot,
dot, dot.
Scott, thank you. So,
yeah, I think is a beckoning that
we should work on that idea. I
absolutely agree. I'm glad you're inside
with these concepts. I don't really know
where they go, but hopefully it's
portals to something like that. Great.
And then one more Scott David question
does fractal identity reveal the
recursivity of rhetoric language
consciousness informing individual
identity from community identity inputs?
Yeah, that's wonderful. So, yeah, my own
thought is like, what is an individual
identity? Right, Scott? So the
reflexivity curve has always sort of
stumped me how there's so much distance
between I and me. And so
it ensumes this notion of continuity
over time. And so I've always said,
what sort of notion of time are we
talking about to even have a consistent
identity? Somehow you always wake up and
everything is still here. Somehow you
wake up and you're not a lobster. I
don't really understand how. That works.
But yeah, that's nice. If you could use
fractal to get something singular from
something communal, that might be cool.
But maybe fractal is something sort of
like you're both at the same time.
And that's what I don't know yet. So I
think it's a totally revolutionary way
of thinking to not have a before after.
So if you can construct identity without
before after, then that's sort of what
I'm trying to do. But, yeah, that's
cool. If you want to get identity from
communal, I think you can do that. They
may also sort of blur.
Well, this is truly food
for thought, and I really hope people
can live with
the darkness, take it and run with it,
because there's so many fun ways to go.
Thank you so much. I hope so, too. So
you're always welcome back. Thank you.
And talk to you later. Thank you so
much. Bye. Good night.